-Today is a day
all about giving thanks,
so why not a better day
to write out my weekly
Thank You Notes right now?
You guys mind?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I'd love to.
James, can I get some
Thank You Note writing music,
please?
♪♪
-Wow.
Thankful.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
Thanksgiving leftovers,
for leading to an epic game
of Fridge Tetris.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
canned cranberry sauce,
for being the only thing
that keeps its shape
after Thanksgiving.
Yeah. Can't mess with that.
I like --
I like a good dessert
to have -- that has abs.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Thank you, World Cup trophy.
-Ooh.
-Because everyone knows
the first rule of soccer
is hold the ball with two hands.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. What?
-What?
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you, peeling potatoes,
for either being a sign
that you're helping Mom or did
something wrong in boot camp.
[ Applause ]
Beetle Bailey!
Get over here!
♪♪
-Thank you, Thanksgiving,
for being that special day
when your family is either upset
you're not married
or upset about
who you did marry.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
"He's a loozah!"
♪♪
Thank you,
airport X-ray machine,
for letting me work off
Thanksgiving
by doing one very slow
jumping jack.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, family photos,
for letting me remember
exactly what mood each family
member was in at the time.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our Thank You Notes.
We'll be right back.